the council agreed on a general approach
on updated rules for the training and
qualifications of professional Orion bus
drivers
this update puts greater emphasis on
safety in the training and will improve
recognition of qualifications across the
European Union the maritime conclusions
identify competitiveness the
carbonization and the digitalization as
guiding principles for a policy in this
area the rule saves the conclusion set a
target of having the number of serious
injuries on roads in the European Union
by 2030 from the 2020 baseline ministers
discussed work on enabling the
International Maritime Organization to
adopt an ambitious and ambitious initial
strategy in 2018 to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions from ships ministers also
expressed their initial views on the
mobility package a generally welcome the
Commission's efforts to clarify the
existing rules and step up enforcement
our very some key parts of the package
will need detailed assessment in respect
of their social economic and also in
some cases the environmental impact let
me be very clear social conditions of
road drivers are at the heart of our
concerns and our proposals aim at
improving the enforcement of EU social
rules and workers rights and road safety
cannot and will not be compromised in
any way the Commission has set out an
agenda to make clean competitive and
connected mobility a reality for all